pants Kennedy for recent TV here in DC I
love bicycling especially when the
government is paying for it Capital
Bikeshare rents bikes right off the
streets in the Washington DC area and
it's dirt cheap thanks to the government
which so far has subsidized the program
to the tune of sixteen million dollars
why do you need a government funding in
order to have a program like this people
can get into expensive bikes Harbinson
DC are small very hard to put a bike you
know come on you saw Seinfeld there's so
many ways of hanging bikes you get the
little hook I thought makes millions of
dollars a year he had a nice apartment
Capital Bikeshare got 1.3 million
dollars from a federal program to quote
address the unique transportation
challenges faced by welfare recipients
and low-income persons seeking to obtain
and maintain employment it's no surprise
that people using Capital Bikeshare are
overwhelmingly college-educated and
white in a city that's not Virginia Tech
did a study of people using bikes in the
bike share program and that is not
indicative of the demographic makeup of
Washington DC why is that it's a good
question then people the early adopters
of our program were people who are
already riding bikes and they tend to
skew mail they tend to skew white and
and educated everyone needs to get on
the bike I've joined a gym that's
expensive so maybe it was someone who
doesn't have as much financial ability
as I do I think it's probably money not
well spent if it's intended to help
low-income people because people who use
Capital Bikeshare tend to not be
low-income okay alright that's that's a
valid point well thank you I think I get
a big W for this one let's face it we
all know biking is awesome but we don't
need government programs to pay for it
all bike happily ever after for reason
TV I'm Kennedy
nice rack